rihanna just joined the billionaires
club
i couldn't tell you how happy i am on
wednesday
forbes announced that the 33 year old
singer has officially become the
wealthiest female musician
in the world and is second only to oprah
winfrey as the richest female
entertainer
sky's the limit no rules i can do
whatever i want the publication
estimates riri's worth has climbed to an
impressive
1.7 billion dollars due in large part
to her ventures in the world of beauty
and fashion
it's like a newborn so you just you have
to nourish it and be hands on and
i've been really excited can't believe
it happened that quickly we've been
working on it
for years fenty beauty which forbes
confirms rihanna is a 50
owner of makes up 1.4 billion
of the mogul's fortune which is super
impressive since she only just launched
the brand in 2017.
thank you when rihanna launched fenty
beauty she
changed the beauty game forever by
debuting an unprecedented foundation
line
that featured 40 shades for people of
all colors
by 2019 the line was expanded to include
50 foundation shades and 50 concealer
colors
being inclusive for me always came
second nature
i see how women become so emotionally
invested and they feel represented they
feel like they can
see themselves on the shelves and the
campaigns
in 2020 rihanna expanded the business to
skin care
and now it's not just women she's
targeting
she wanted to make sure her fenty skin
line not only worked for all skin
tones and types but that it was also
gender inclusive
so she called up friends like her
boyfriend asap rocky
and lilna's ex to star in the campaign
shoot
i wanted men to be represented because
this
skincare line is gender neutral i want
it to be for everyone
and so you don't men get scared
to use skin care they think it's like a
feminine thing they think it's just for
girls and
i don't i don't like that idea because
we all have skin we all wear skin
and so i needed that male representation
in the campaigns
as for the rest of rihanna's fortune it
comes from her stake in her lingerie
company
savage by fenty worth an estimated 270
million dollars
and of course her earnings from being a
top-charting musician
and actress
back in february it was announced that
the a-list star's lingerie and
loungewear brand had reached a one
billion dollar valuation in lingerie
equity
with forbes estimating that it will be
quote the global lingerie market leader
by 2025.
i love it so i guess it's safe to say
rihanna can retire
this track pay me what you want me
[Applause]
to lebron [ __ ] give me your money